[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be talking about a major
development in the big theory that I
have been talking about on this channel
for a few months in episode 125 the
grand priest gave us another major clue
that this theory could be true so I had
to make a quick update video with the
recent news that Dragon Ball super will
stop broadcasting on Japanese TV at the
end of March 2018 there has been a lot
of speculation of what is going to
happen with the tournament of power and
with Dragon Ball super in general is
Dragon Ball super ending completely
after the tournament of power is the
series just going on a break and coming
back later or is there going to be a
brand new Dragon Ball series or spin-off
sometime in the future if you want to
stick around until the end of this video
I will share my thoughts on what I think
is going to happen next with Dragon Ball
super but first we need to talk about
this theory because it is even more
important now that the future of Dragon
Ball super is uncertain and we don't
know what is next for the story if you
are new to the channel consider
subscribing for more videos like this
one and now let's get into it
I won't go over all of the details again
in this video because I talked about it
in great detail in the previous two
videos dealing with this theory so I
will link those at the end of this video
and also in the description if you want
to check them out I don't want to repeat
myself too much and take up too much of
your time but to make a long story short
in the previous videos I argued that
Dragon Ball super has spent a lot of
time showing us how board Zeno is most
of the time at least until the
tournament of power starts at which
point we are shown over and over again
just how much bold xenos are loving the
tournament and having the times of their
lives watching all of the epic battles
between the different universes we also
know that in the past when Xena was
bored or in a bad mood he was known to
do extreme things like he raised six
entire universes before the tournament
even began the theory that I put forward
states that the grand priest is actually
good and not a villain like some people
seem to think and that the grand priest
is using the term
power to teach Zen Oh who obviously
seems very naive and childish a very
important lesson I think that the grand
priest saw how bored Zen Oh usually is
and he also saw how Zen Oh can get into
a bad mood and do terrible things like
he raised six entire universes so the
grand priest decided to use the
tournament of power to make Zen Oh
finally understand the consequences of
his actions as someone who is both
childish and naive and yet so powerful
that he exists on a completely higher
plane than mortals do Zen Oh doesn't
really seem to understand that his
actions are hurting people in episode 77
we see the xenos playing a game or they
are flicking planets into each other
like they were marbles but when the
planets hit each other
the xennos are only seeing it as a
hologram a projection and they don't see
the actual destruction that their
actions are causing in the real world
in this sense Zeno is living in a sort
of bubble where he is insulated from the
consequences of his actions and never
has to face them however with the
tournament of power everything changes
the xenos are now watching an epic
showdown between the mortals of eight
different universes up close and
personal and they are having a great
time keeping score and watching all of
the fights and cool and interesting
moves and techniques previously Zeno
probably had little to no interaction
with mortals at all so he didn't even
see them as people but now because of
the tournament Zeno sees that mortals
can be a lot of fun they are interesting
intelligent some of them are very
powerful and they can be really
entertaining to watch
since Zeno hates being bored the fact
that mortals can be so entertaining
means that they have value they are not
just insects whose existence doesn't
even matter so my theory was this the
grand priest knew that Zeno would love
the tournament and have a great time
watching it and he knew that as a result
of the tournament Zeno would see how
interesting mortals can be the grand
priest also know that Zeno lives forever
he is immortal so when the tournament of
power is over Zeno will still have an
eternity of boredom ahead of him this
was already foreshadowed back in
1:20 when the xenos are looking at their
god pads and they notice how many
fighters have already been eliminated at
this point they say soon it'll be over
and they both appear to be clearly
disappointed right after that the grand
priest assures the xenos that there are
still some great battles ahead but the
fact remains that the tournament has to
end soon at the end of the tournament
only one universe will survive and seven
will be erased that means that along
with the four universes that didn't have
to compete in the tournament there are
five universes left all together now
here's where the events of episode 125
come into play as dispo is facing off
against Frieza he is moving so fast that
the xenos cannot follow not even when
they are using the slow-motion function
on their god paths at this point the
grand priest says the dispo speed
appears to be far beyond the capacity of
the god pad he then goes on to add and I
quote Zeno sama next time I shall
prepare a more high spec God pack now
it's easy to overlook this quick scene
because we were focusing on the fight
between dispo and Frieza but when you
stop and think about it what does the
grand priest mean by next time the only
thing that this could be referring to is
the next time there is a tournament that
the xennos are watching and need to keep
up with the incredibly fast movements of
the fighters now we were led to believe
that there is only ever going to be one
tournament of power but this is a very
strong foreshadowing that there is going
to be another tournament a new
tournament sometime in the future this
takes us right back to the fact that
Zeno is so often bored except during the
tournament of power when he is having a
blast my theory was that once the
tournament ends Zeno will be very
disappointed with the prospect of living
for eternity and never experiencing such
a fun event again and at this point the
grand priest will suggest holding
another tournament of power sometime in
the future or better yet holding
multiple tournaments that happen every
few years or so like the Olympics where
each universe can
show off their best warriors and compete
for the title of strongest in all of
existence this new tournament or
tournaments could take place between
just a remaining five universes but five
teams is not as fun as eight or
potentially even more so what if the
grand priest suggests to xeno to bring
back all the erased universes in
exchange for having them all compete in
this tournament regularly every few
years or so if this happened it would
make everything that the grand priest
has done up to this point make perfect
sense the grand priest realizes that
Zeno is often bored and when he gets
bored and moody bad things happen
maybe one day Xena will decide to erase
all of existence on a whim so the grand
priest decides to teach Zeno that
mortals have value and can cure xenos
boredom Zeno then witnesses the
tournament of power sees that mortals
are fun and have value and he wants to
keep enjoying the tournament in the
future so he decides to undo the bad
things he has done in the past and he
brings back the erased universes and
stops erasing mortals on a whim because
he understands their value and
importance not in this way the grand
priest saves the multiverse and teaches
a no unimportant less and without
confronting Zeno directly because of
course Zeno is too strong to force into
anything Zeno can't be forced to do
anything because he is the strongest he
has to be persuaded and taught a lesson
through the tournament and what does all
this mean for the story it opens up a
ton of new possibilities with new
tournaments coming up in the future new
universes potentially competing with
each other and so on and maybe Zeno even
decides to bring back the six universes
that were erased before the tournament
so that they can compete too which means
that the story has six new universes to
uncover and plenty of material to work
with for future arcs I really think that
Dragon Ball super is heavily
foreshadowing that this tournament of
power will not be the last
xeno is just having way too much fun so
I really think that more tournaments are
going to happen we don't know how soon
we don't know what the rules and
regulations of these new tournaments
will be but I am confident that this is
where the story is taking us more and
more clues are pointing in this same
direction if you want to explore this
theory in greater detail with more point
by point breakdowns I will link my
previous two videos in the description
and at the end of this video let me know
your thoughts let me know if you agree
is the grand priest using the tournament
to teach Zeno an important lesson about
mortals and is he planning to convince
Zeno to hold more tournaments in the
future also how do you think that the
recent news we got that Dragon Ball
super will no longer be broadcasting
weekly on Japanese TV will affect the
end of the tournament and the story as a
whole personally I think that even
though Dragon Ball super might be going
on a hiatus this is not the end of the
Dragon Ball franchise by a long shot a
new Dragon Ball movie is already
confirmed for December 2018 and just
like the movies Battle of the Gods and
resurrection F resulted in the creation
of Dragon Ball super I am sure that the
new movie means that either a new
spinoff series or a continuation of
Dragon Ball super is on the way
if Dragon Ball wasn't profitable and
they had to cancel draggable super
because of that then there would not be
a major movie scheduled to come out at
the end of this year the fact that the
movie is on its way means that of course
Dragon Ball is profitable and as long as
the franchise is popular and profitable
then I am sure that we don't have to
worry about the franchise ending anytime
soon at any rate I grew up with Dragon
Ball Dragon Ball Z is one of the biggest
reasons why I got into anime in the
first place so no matter what happens
you can expect more Dragon Ball content
here on this channel in the future if
you enjoy these videos and want to see
more be sure to leave a like to let me
know and if you're new to the channel
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell we are now posting
daily anime content on Twitter and
Instagram so be sure to follow us there
at anime uproar and if you'd like to
support this channel and get cool anime
merch at the same time like Keep Calm
and ultra instinct or your girl calls me
senpai you can check out our merch store
in the description as always thank you
all so much for watching and until next
time see us space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]